dans ce lycée acajou 2 les épreuves du
contrôle continu doivent débuter lundi
prochain langues histoire géo matt des
épreuves pourtant compromise par la
mobilisation d'une grande partie des
enseignants et les organisations de
parents d'élèves ne leur jette pas la
pierre depuis plus d'un an en effet la
communauté scolaire parle de
précipitation dans l'élaboration de
cette réforme du bac
elle dénonce également l'inégalité entre
les épreuves choisies par les
établissements eux mêmes
c'est le même gros demande de cris de
souffrance qui se fait de par le pays
quand son enfance quand je prends
martini et c'est normal qu'en martinique
nous puissions prendre part à cette à
cette révolte si je puis m'exprimer
ainsi pour dire que les systèmes de
réponse qui nous ont proposés sont trop
précipités dès que c'est pas adaptées
depuis le 5 décembre et le début de la
grève contre la réforme des retraites
les lycéens n'ont pratiquement pas eu
cours pour l'upm les premières ne sont
pas du tout prêts pour les épreuves du
contrôle continu
lorsque nous avons le comité de suivi de
cette réforme qui a été mise en place à
la mi décembre
après de nombreux mois sans organisation
de transport par le rectorat pour la
mise en oeuvre des spécialités
comment peut-on organiser des épreuves
de contrôle continu alors que dix
enfants n'ont même pas eu un mois de
cours sur ses spécialités
je veux qu'on m'explique comment c'est
tout bonnement inimaginable c'est
extraordinaire ce qui se passe dans
cette académie unis arié de politique
dans cette démarche nous avons des
professionnels qui sont à vous qui n'ont
pas les moyens aujourd'hui d'assumer
leurs missions
bien sûr les groupements de parents
d'élèves se disent consternés de voir
tant de jours d'enseignement perdu alors
on la vit des lycées reste rythmé par
les assemblées générales le flou reste
entier sur les modalités d'organisation
des nouvelles épreuves du contrôle
continu